[Musique]
le projet de la nar de vinci 6 et pas
seulement un beau château pour le roi a
c'est une ville pour la cour c'est
l'idée de mettre la ville au centre d'un
réseau de canaux de voies navigables à
la fois c'est un projet de palais royal
de ville pour la couronne de
développement économique de toute une
région
et les grandioses parce que il ya des
prouesses techniques comme amener l'eau
d'une rivière dans une autre il y est
grandiose parce que il permettait en fin
de compte à léonard de vinci de mettre
en pratique toutes les chaussures lequel
il travaille est depuis des dizaines
d'années
en italie des j'en avais réfléchi au
problème d'hygiène par exemple léonard
avait conçu des villes à trois niveaux
avec un nouveau souterrain pour les
canalisations pour évacuer les eaux
sales un niveau avec des canaux vont
rapporter les marchandises un niveau
supérieur pour les piétons
[Musique]
sylvie en france et pour ce projet donc
il vient travailler dessus très
rapidement et on sait qu'au cours de
l'année 1917 ya des gros travaux qui
commencent ce plan d'arpentage donc a
été tracée mesurée par franchise comédie
est à noter par léonard ça c'est
l'écriture du canard ils ont mais rsa
avec un instrument qui s'appelle une
boussole à qui ne mesure non pas les
points cardinaux béliveau dans les
comptes de la ville on a des milliers
des milliers des milliers de charette
qui apporte la marne pour faire le
terre-plein 400 m de long sur 4 5 mètres
de haut
donc c'est les travaux énormes cette
grande levée de terre est bel et bien
été construites ce qu'on la retrouve
encore aujourd'hui sur le terrain et il
ya même des canalisations en dessous
il restait dans l'ombre parce que y'a
rien n'a été construit il n'y a pas de
mur qu'ils se sont élevées enfin bon y'a
pas un début de construction à part le
terre-plein qui n'est pas spectaculaire
ça s'arrête ce au cours de l'année 1518
puisque léonard et donc et âgées et les
malades et le projet tellement complexe
que seul lui peut le mener à bien
l'hydraulique c'est la passion première
de léonard les personnes peuvent prendre
la suite de ça c'est la raison
principale de l'arrêt du projet